[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah yeah we're
uh
talking about uh that
like in night of living dead the 2001 no
1990 or 1991 the remake yeah we actually
because uh if you were here friday or
whenever the hell we were live streaming
um i was talking about when before we
went to uh halloween kills we were at
the mall across the street and we went
in fye and they always had that big bin
in the front that was all those movies
for cheap and they had like a big horror
one too and they were they were selling
stuff off for like five dollars and so
they had the night of living dead from
1990 and i was kind of like oh man i
remember this actually being pretty good
uh so and i hadn't seen it for a long
time so we decided to pick it up for
cheap and then i was kind of in the mood
to watch it last night so we re-watched
it and it's actually i remember it being
good like when i saw it i think i might
have seen it in the theater back in 1990
um it's actually like better than i
remembered yeah i remember liking it but
i'd forgotten everything about it i
forgot that tony todd was starting it he
was ben yeah and he did a great job as
ben
there was a
i mean they were doing the kind of retro
1960s acting
like right out of night of living dead
now uh they did make some changes to the
script
but they wanted to kind of get make it a
little fresh so it's not like you're
watching the exact same movie yeah
although it's way closer to the original
than i had remembered and the thing
about it this well what ended up
happening um in case you guys didn't
know because david june said wait a 1990
remake i've not seen this yeah yeah um
what ended up happening was that
obviously i think a lot of people know
like the original george romero night of
living dead from 1968 there were all
these kind of like copyright issues
there were you know paperwork fuck-ups
and everything like that so they lost
the copyright on it so kind of like
george romero and all the crew and stuff
like that didn't really get a lot of
money out of it even though it kind of
became a cult classic later on
so what they were afraid like when the
90s uh you know or the late 80s kind of
came about they sort of george romero
and uh his kind of production company
they sort of got wind that a lot of
other production companies were maybe
like kind of interested in doing a
remake of night of the living dead and
because he didn't no longer had the
copyright on it he wasn't going to get
anything for it so he decided to go
through his own production company and
raise the money and make one themselves
to kind of like still be like hey this
is our movie you know what i mean you
can't just like make it out of the
[ __ ] i mean they could legally the
first one was uh you know it was public
domain
yeah yeah they [ __ ] up the paperwork
yeah you could play it anywhere
yep a lot of people don't know
this but um there were there were whole
[ __ ] theaters ghetto theaters that
made a [ __ ] living off of [ __ ]
showing night of living dead [ __ ]
at midnight
on the weekends and uh
when i was growing up in california
our local television stations that might
have been channel 13 i think it was kt
tv
they would play night of the living dead
and the first time i saw it i must have
been about six i think it was 1976 that
was 19 probably 1976 1977
so i'd have been about eight
maybe nine something
dependent eight seven eight nine around
that time
and i woke up early to see the cartoons
all right but it was way early i didn't
know what time it was i couldn't you
know read a clock i guess i don't know i
don't remember i just remember not
really knowing what time it was it was
just the sun hadn't come up yet and
turned it on and there was this [ __ ]
black and white movie
that was
intriguing it started pulling me in and
i didn't know it was neither living dead
that's exactly what it was and when they
remember the first thing when they get
into that damn house and you see the
skull and the blood and like that that's
when i knew i was in for trouble that
[ __ ] movie
sucked me in and it just it it [ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] out of me and i [ __ ]
loved it and then it was over
the uh
they played uh they did like a little
quick like national anthem thing and
then in california the cartoons start
right up
happy nightmares here's the zombies
yeah here's bugs buddy i think it must
have been saturday morning cartoons or
something so that was like the really
really late friday we're in the really
late show so i'm supposed to woke up
around three in the morning or something
three or four in the morning and [ __ ]
they just started putting on because it
was free so i guess those dudes
running the damn local
the local tv stations is that putting
that living dead on because there'd be
[ __ ] that come on in those california uh
after hours in the local california
television stations wouldn't be even in
it wasn't even announced in the
tv guide yeah they just put some rent
well you could do with not a living dead
because it was public public domain yeah
and you know you didn't have to pay
anybody well there was a whole bunch of
ghetto theaters that in the middle of
the night would play [ __ ]
night of the living dead
and
if you're outside the united states and
you weren't black you didn't know that
[ __ ] most black kids
grew up watching night of living dead
back in the 70s because it had a it had
a [ __ ] african-american star
which was very very rare but yeah very
unusual yeah and a ghetto theater back
in the 70s didn't care how old you were
so they were little kids [ __ ] 9 10 11
going in there
zombies
yeah i've heard whole stories about it
you know from old podcasters or people
that you know from my generation that
grew up i saw those things bootleg in
the local ghetto theater at [ __ ]
midnight well there's a documentary i
think it's still on shutter called
horror noir which is kind of about um
you know black horror history and uh
they a lot of them like tell that story
that night living dead was one of their
big that was one of the big things like
in the late 60s early 70s that would
play at like midnight movie theaters
like in these really like you know kind
of uh and just like really cheap
theaters it was a movie of its time but
it's in many ways it was ahead of its
time and a lot of that by accident
it was underground
um movie making
[ __ ] super bad budget high creativity
level
and the script didn't really happen you
know the script didn't make any mentions
of people's race or anything just the
best actor they had got the lead he had
to be black and that threw a whole new
dynamic on this movie
which in the 60s played [ __ ] super
well now you take it for granted but in
the 60s it was just off yeah it was like
a big deal even though they weren't
really like thinking about it i don't
think like george romero wasn't thinking
about it
in that role yeah he was dwayne jones by
the way who uh fun fact would go on to
direct uh movies of his own such as
ganja and hess which i think is also on
shutter he was a uh he was a theater
teacher i think at the time yeah i think
yeah he got the job yeah and he was
probably coaching the other actors too
while they were making the movie you
know but they were just having having a
good time and that movie the original
really was the blueprint for survival
horror
and it was felt like you were watching a
newsreel
and you felt like you were watching real
people in a [ __ ] weird situation
they don't know what the hell's going on
the tv is telling them one thing they're
seeing something else and then
eventually the tv fesses up and says we
believe that the dead are returning to
life and attacking the living just all
kind and then they're like yeah yeah we
knew that
well i mean admittedly you would really
have to like get confirmation of that
before you reported it to everybody you
know what i mean because it sounds like
unbelievable yeah it's if you haven't
seen the original you must see the
original i mean you can see it
everywhere because like i said it's free
there's no copyright on it so it's like
everywhere has got it right and what
made the movie great is that all the
characters made sense
uh they were kind of based on people you
would actually know or run into and if
you've ever been in an emergency
situation or basic training like the
[ __ ] down the bunker there are dudes
like that and they don't make it because
they're they're so scared they can't
[ __ ] listen and they're blaming
everybody else for [ __ ] little and
they won't do anything they're just
frozen with terror and then they get
hostile and don't want to cooperate
you'll see that all the personality
types are
[ __ ] presented in the original all
right and then [ __ ] ben
ben is just your average dude who's
reasonable trying to get through this
situation he's protecting this woman
who's lost her mind she's totally
helpless she snaps out of a little bit
but she ends up getting killed and then
there's reasonable people and
unreasonable people and a young guy that
helps him out and
it was just a good story about
bravery and cowardice really is what it
was about and uh ben happened to be the
hero
and you
at the end you think there's maybe hope
but no
there's no hope
and how it ends in the original
ben
gets mistaken as a for a zombie by a
[ __ ] basically a lynch mob or a
militia of zombie killers and they just
[ __ ] shoot him in the head from a
long distance and then later on to go in
there and get him with a damn
bale hook and [ __ ] drag him out and
burn him like he's a zombie
which sucks the air right out of the
damn movie oh man it was [ __ ] the
[ __ ] was all for nothing you know which
played real well in the 60s because you
know they had the whole mississippi
burning thing going on and there was a
time of turmoil
so the [ __ ] militia lynch mob type
thing was
like part of the damn riot culture that
was going on at the time it was just a
very much a 60s movie
but it's timeless it's timeless and it's
[ __ ] you know
today with all the trouble going on
right now there it actually kind of
still resonates
so when they did this one when they
rebooted it in in in [ __ ] 1990 i was
in the army so i didn't see it i saw it
later and forgot about it and i forgot
tony todd was in it
they did a perfect
casting when it came to putting tony
todd in there as as ben he's [ __ ]
he's a great ben he's a slightly
different bend but it's him because it
ends a little bit differently
but um
and barbara is a little bit different i
don't agree with everything they did in
this movie i think they should have
included the television as a character
because in the original the television
is a character
the television is telling you what the
hell's going on and it's kind of
painting it's putting this movie in in
its universe it's painting the universe
out and
there is a television in this but it's
its role has been diminished that's the
main thing i disagree with
and i think there was something good
about
having barbara basically a helpless
influence for for most of the movie
because it put a lot of pressure on ben
to try to help her so she was a burden
at first she never really got out of it
now
some people say that i wouldn't fly
today you know what i mean with the way
women's roles but the thing is that
movie had other strong women in it it's
just that barbara was kind of the
helpless one
uh other than that
i think this movie knocked it out of the
park i liked it
i mean this is very similar and i will
note too in case you didn't know that
george romero actually did write the
screenplay for this as well yeah so it's
based on his original screenplay he just
changed a couple things
and uh he brought in
he was uh initially like tom savini came
in to do the effects but then george
romero obviously george mayor and tom
savini had worked together a lot
previously and uh so george murray was
like why don't you just direct it tom
savanny uh so thomas fannie said sure
i'd be glad to problem is
that the producers that they had who
were like giving them the money like the
backers they didn't like a lot of the
ideas so tom savini uh came out later
and said that maybe forty percent of
what i wanted in this movie like came
out the way i wanted um which movie to
talk about the this is the no the 1990
one okay the one that tom savini
directed okay tom savini didn't work on
that yeah and this first one was romero
i think right yeah yeah yeah um so he's
like so maybe and george romero like uh
for whatever reason like he wasn't um on
set a lot of the time for the 1991 even
though he did write the screenplay
but um
so
yeah so tom savini had a lot of kind of
clashes with the producers who didn't
want to do certain things but it but
honestly even despite that um i think
this came out actually
really good and normally i'm not a huge
fan of remakes i don't you know i don't
[ __ ] on them like just out of the gate
because it's like you know there have
been good ones obviously um you know and
i think that this was actually one of
the better ones and watching it again
last night it was actually way better
than i remember and what's interesting
too i think because i remembered tom
savini directing it so i think knowing
that in my mind
i remembered it being much gorier than
it was but it's actually hardly gory at
all
and then when i was reading about it tom
savini was like well yeah he's like well
i didn't really want to make it over the
top gory he's like yeah i know that's
what i'm known for but he's like i felt
like in respect to the original which
wasn't really all that gory he kind of
wanted to go
more like the more like the old one like
more of the tone of the old one so he
didn't want to make it like this over
the top splatter fast yeah it feels like
the 60s feels like it's placed in the
60s but i don't really think it is it
might i think it's supposed to be the
90s
yeah it's supposed to be contemporary
it does have a 60s style as a 60s feel
to it it feels like the original
i kind of want to say this is tony
todd's best movie it's his best role i
think yeah it's hard to say between that
and candy man i'm gonna say that i i
don't know man i think this might be he
was he's really good
he's he's ready
he's got a bigger part in it
he really does i think capture the
character of ben that's that's ben
um he doesn't put a big twist on it and
when he does bend he does a lot of the
same acting
kind of
foibles and imperfections that were in
the original actor that played ben he
he's doing like a i don't want to say
it's a
a ben impression
it's just like he's channeling that
character yeah it's like an homage but
he's kind of putting his own spin on it
yeah even the way he's delivering lines
because the original actor
a lot of what he was doing was ad-libbed
and he was trying to find the words
to add to
for the situation and todd does the same
thing it's kind of like him kind of
stumbling over fumbling on a line and
trying to save it it's good it's it's
like watching the original band i think
he did a great job i really liked all
the actors in this interestingly
patricia tallman who plays barbara which
is probably the biggest change from this
movie to from the original she's
actually she was in some other stuff i
think she was in babylon 5 or something
like that she's mostly known for being a
stunt performer
um so i think this was kind of like as
far as acting goes this might have been
like one of her bigger ones i've seen
her before i was trying to place her she
was on babylon 5. and i think she was in
some star trek as well like on some star
trek but like i said mostly most of her
career is like stunt work she's she's a
stunt person yeah she's very different
version of barbara better looking a lot
more athletic and heroic
well they do a break from the original
yeah well like i said at this point you
know we had like all the horror movie
slasher movies and stuff like that from
the 80s and the whole final girl thing
was just very established so i kind of
feel like maybe they wanted to go more
in that direction because that was
something that was you know and i think
that some even horror fans had
complained about for a long time about
barbara from the original 1968 one how
she just kind of like sat there and
didn't do anything it was like useless
um which like like you said you you
could see
you liked her being useless because one
there were other women in the movie that
weren't useless yeah and two uh you know
like you said it put more pressure on
ben to like protect her because she'd
clearly lost her lost her mind because
she saw her
because she saw her brother get killed
so you can understand it what they did
with this one
is that barbara
starts out like that like she gets to
the house and she doesn't talk for like
a long time because she's in shock as
you would be if you saw like dead people
get up and start walking around and
killing people that you love but um
but she like uh you know about 10-15
minutes and she kind of snaps out of it
and like starts
taking care of [ __ ] um so she has more
of a
a heroic thing and they end it
differently too even though kind of the
outcome of it is sort of similar but
uh they give her more of like a final
girl type of thing yeah which like i
kind of like that i mean i like that
they
you know the the movie is very very
close to the original like i said it's
still a george romero script uh they
didn't change a [ __ ] ton of stuff
and um but i do like that they made that
change to it because if they just made
the same thing and you know what's
ironic when this first came out in 1990
a lot of critics didn't like it because
they thought well it's just like the
original so why bother yeah yeah um but
you know
just like a lot of things as time went
on uh you know critical a pre-appraisal
and it got like a lot more this one aged
real well it did actually and like i
said i i hadn't seen it for a very long
time and re-watching i was like wow this
is actually like way better than i
remembered it
it's still good the reason why i didn't
like the new barber that much is because
in the original there was the movie was
set up a lot of it was
two
stories of two different guys
on two doing two different power plays
you had the married white guy cooper
cooper
who was down in the basement hunkered
down
and he was trying to protect his wife
and family
but not it really in a good way it's
kind of like toxic masculinity he's kind
of like the dude from the hand
all right yeah that dude he's a giant
[ __ ] [ __ ] giant dude she's real
abusive he's abusive towards the damn
woman that he's trying to protect yeah
he smacks her in the face yes man and
then he's he's [ __ ] won't help you
won't help them fortify the upper floors
uh he's not making any long-term plans
about escaping in case the [ __ ]
zombies get in the house there's no way
out of the basement ben is right at
least you got a second floor which they
don't get into the second floor in this
movie as much in the first movie
remember the second floor played a big
role they went up there they were
throwing fire bombs off
and so there was a little bit there was
a tactical advantage to having a second
floor
so ben was more right you had a place a
way to get out
yeah because there were more than one
there's more than one exit right
now ben he's kind of he's not protecting
his family he's protecting himself in an
adopted family which is barbara
barbara's kind of like a child in a way
she's mentally [ __ ] up she can't
do anything you know what i mean in the
original in the original so she's
totally helpless and he's trying to
reason with her and he's trying to be
the leader uh he uh a young white guy
and his girlfriend joined him and then
late uh to fortify the place later on
uh what's his name cooper yeah yeah
cooper's the jackal cooper's wife calls
him out you're an [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and agrees with uh um ben
now this great scene in the original all
right which was even more powerful in
the [ __ ] 60s ben beats the [ __ ] out
of cooper all right so you had a
justifiably so because yeah dude was
such a [ __ ] dude he's gonna get
everybody killed yeah and that goes to
the whole survival horror angle
what society says is right and wrong
don't does not [ __ ] matter in a
survival situation it's what is correct
tactically
and
ben was correct
he had to [ __ ] beat cooper's [ __ ]
ass to get [ __ ] done if not they were
they you know he was going to get his
party
killed and really on those kind of
dynamics is what made the survival
horror genre and the whole walking dead
thing came from [ __ ] like that
and in the 1990 remake
they have some of that or they did play
on that but that original formula wasn't
there and i kind of missed it but i do
under i do i do agree
it it may have not have been wise to
totally redo that first story why remake
that movie yeah if you're gonna make it
exactly the same so i kind of see that
argument
because the fans get two versions
okay
and you everybody has two versions you
can watch either you can watch both
these movies so it's not like that story
was untold it was told yeah they just
retold it and they omitted certain
things
my main gripe was the television
well see my argument was because what
okay so in the original like you said um
you know the tv provided a lot of like
uh exposition of like what was going on
world building and stuff what was going
on outside of the world of this one
farmhouse
in 1990 they do find a tv upstairs and
they do kind of they plug it in and then
there's like a um
you know one of those what do you call
it like the
emergency broadcast system yeah type of
thing and it's telling you it's there
for a couple of minutes um and then
they're just kind of like okay well you
know whatever but they don't know
exactly what's going on yet and then
cooper like uh like the douchebag that
he is later he kind of sneaks upstairs
while everybody's trying to fortify the
house and tries to take the tv and like
tries to take it down to the basement or
you know that's we you don't know if
that's what he's doing but that's what
it looks like he's doing um and so then
ben catches him and they get into like
this big scuffle and the tv ends up like
falling down the basement stairs and
getting broken
now i would argue like i see what you're
saying like i like that you like that
whole thing with the tv and and that is
like a really cool part of the original
but i would argue that because most
people have seen the original and most
in 1990 everybody knew what a zombie was
everybody knew
you know you know everybody knew that
dead people were walking around so i
would argue that maybe it was kind of
like a waste of time
to take time out of the movie to say oh
you know the dead are coming back to
life everybody knows that in 1990 even
even in the context of the movie they
don't know that in the context of the
movie but audiences now well the reason
why i liked it in the original version
is because it it
it's not only the world building it's
also kind of like
a truism that you learn
through the television you learn that
the media and the government don't know
what the [ __ ] going on don't believe
the truth and then later on it shows the
military and the government complex
trying to hide the truth remember
they don't really want to talk about the
satellite and the radiation because
they're afraid that maybe they're
responsible it takes them a while to
finally that they're forced to admit
that the [ __ ] dead are coming back to
life
and they may have something to do with
it
and i i liked that yeah
i liked that element dad that they
showed that they showed the leadership
in chaos and they showed the leadership
lying and trying to be evasive about it
not not wanting to talk
and i just i just thought that was great
because that would that's what
when a society is unraveling that's what
you see
and that's what happened
[ __ ] that's 1990 brings it back to the
[ __ ] first gulf war
and [ __ ] everything saddam hussein's
minister of [ __ ] truth and minister
of propaganda they were definitely
saying
the exact opposite of what is true
you're all safe don't worry the
americans are all dead out in the sands
you know just that kind of [ __ ] you know
so
i just thought those were great touches
and it was because people in the 60s
were used to that they were being lied
to and they all knew it
yeah vietnam war and [ __ ]
and a lot of those [ __ ] riots and
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] lying on a pretty
regular basis
yeah that's what i was trying to like uh
comment on some of the stuff that was up
here but um yeah tom savini actually did
want to work on the original film but
obviously he was uh in vietnam at that
time that was 1968. uh mike barrett says
the original barber is pretty much
comatose for the whole movie yeah pretty
much uh it's just kind of like finally
finally she snaps out of it like near
the end and comes and tries to help them
like put the doors up and then gets
killed when she sees her zombified
brother she flips out again and gets uh
eaten which i thought that was great i
thought that was great because it it
gave it added to the sense of
hopelessness for certain people yeah and
i mean everybody still gets killed in
the [ __ ] but there's some dilation
that's buffering
some die later that's the only
difference they all died yeah just some
died earlier and some died later
david june is asking where can you watch
this actually i'm not sure uh we just
ended up watching it because i bought it
at fye bought a hard copy and uh but you
can probably i imagine it might be on to
be or somewhere like that just like
putting night of living dead in 1990 or
night night living dead tom cevini
out there you'll like it and then david
june says the best barber is sean of the
dead barbara
and then he said this is funny
oh and i wanted to mention this too yeah
bill moseley
who
has been a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] horror
movies most recently at all the rob
zombie ones uh he played barbara's
brother in this 1991 although he gets
killed like immediately
and then he sort of like and he doesn't
even come back to the house as a zombie
does he i think that barbara after she
kind of escapes from the house she sees
his dead body like in the back of a
truck or something yeah
so so she doesn't get killed so spoiler
alert she actually doesn't get killed at
the end everyone else does but um
uh maybe on shutter i don't actually
think i think the original is on shutter
but i don't think that the remake is on
shutter it might be on to be though
because 2b tends to have stuff like this
i don't know it might be hard to get i
should have checked like where it was
streaming i guess i didn't really think
about it because we just bought the dvd
like him didn't just watched it on that
was there even was there any extras on
that
oh yeah but we didn't see him oh okay we
didn't know if there was any extras on
there you were tired remember oh yeah
that's right i was like yeah i can't
yeah they're they're special
yeah we'll have to we'll have to watch
it we got the uh
the dvd version and it was only five
bucks yeah and uh
we watched it on my xbox 360 on a big
[ __ ]
hd [ __ ] tv it looks great i don't
think you didn't you don't need a
blu-ray for it
it looks good no not really i mean like
i said it's not like it's some big like
cinematic no anything like that and
honestly intro flick i think if you've
seen it in real ultra hd you just
wouldn't that the special effects
probably wouldn't have looked as good
although as i said
considering that tom savini worked on
this and directed it it's not as gory as
you might think um you see a lot of
gunshots and stuff like that but it's
not anything like
you know it's nothing like people
getting scalped or beheaded or anything
like that like some of his other because
you know tom savini did a lot of uh you
know [ __ ] with george romero like dawn
of the dead and stuff you see a lot a
lot of the walking dead in it now
yeah you see where the walking dead got
a lot of inspiration from well all the
zombie movies but this one too yeah the
town
but yeah i mean i honestly like i said
you can kind of are i don't know you
could like argue all day long about you
know barbara and the original and
barbara and this one
um i kind of like that
like i said they almost went two ways
with it because barbara at first
at the beginning of this movie she is
kind of like the barber from the
original because like i said she's
clearly in shock and she's not really
talking at first like she doesn't really
know what's going on like she's
shell-shocked sort of um but then she
you know she actually starts talking and
starts like contributing [ __ ] like you
know she's the one that looks out the
window and says hey look how slow they
are we could just walk past them
um and then everyone else like you nuts
we're just like [ __ ] staying in here
and so and she's also the ones the one
that calls out like all the arguing
between the dudes because it's like
they're not getting anything done
because yeah telling them they're acting
like two-year-olds yeah well that was
cooper's fault
well yeah that didn't have anything to
do with ben because like you said ben
was right i would i wouldn't want to
like go down the down go down the bent
down basement because like i said the
zombies get in there you [ __ ] where
are you gonna go you know ben got forced
down into the basement later because
everybody got killed because oh boy
wouldn't help but [ __ ] secure the place
yeah they got to secure the place early
uh and had they found the damn key to
the fuel it would have been a different
story remember but he the key to the
fuel was down there in the basement with
[ __ ] cooper with that douchebag
he probably knew it was there because it
was just hanging there well see that was
the implication because i kind of feel
like like i said just in the original
movie ben does eventually get forced out
of the cellar um whether he wanted to or
not but yeah in this version i don't
think that was in the original version
where there was like that's where the
key to the to the he was never found in
here yeah i don't think they ever found
the key
um but yeah they did find the key and he
just like looks at it he's just like oh
isn't that you know a kick in the head
and i was like oh the universe hates me
so it's that kind of [ __ ] but uh yeah so
he's like
but like i said other than that it's
very similar but i don't think it's so
similar that it didn't need to be made
and we were talking about last night
because i said you know
like i said that's why i'm not that's
why i don't [ __ ] on like horror remakes
it's like yeah you know they shouldn't
rely on let's just remake the same
[ __ ] movies over and over all the
time because i like to see original ones
too
but i'm not averse to the idea
in principle as long as you're
respecting the source material and
you're kind of doing your own thing on
it
your own thing with it which i think
this was i think this was a good balance
between
respecting the original and doing enough
different that you know there was
something else in it if you so yeah so
it's not like oh well if you saw one of
them you don't have to see the other one
i think it's interesting to watch them
both and compare and then another thing
i was saying too was that in 1988
they did a remake of the blob which is
fantastic that remake of the ball i
think it was 88 yeah
uh with kevin dillon was in it right
yeah it was around the time that they
what was it man that was good
i think not mars attacks around the type
of one of uh the ones that the martian
invasion what was that one
ah where they had the damn head in the
damn bowl and [ __ ] remember um
well i mean mars attacks was the tim
burton no not down before that one
invaders from invaders remarks was that
the toby hooper one there was a remake
around the late 80s it was good but i
want to see that one again i haven't
seen that one in a long time remember
the little boy's parents got taken over
no yeah that's right yeah i want to see
that one i remember that not doing very
well no it didn't but i liked it i saw
it on hbo i'm pretty sure toby hooper
directed that yeah please correct me if
i'm wrong but uh both movies are good
the basic theme is of survival horror
and sub which is the essence of survival
horror is the overturning of the net of
the of the normal social order in
society returning back to the animal
order you know [ __ ] dudes beating
each other's asses their station or
color or socioeconomic none of that
matters only their abilities matter uh
the people that used to be the pariahs
you know like the rednecks they were
kind of made fun of them but [ __ ] at
the end of the movie they're a huge army
a huge militia and [ __ ] barbara who's
like was she was like a yuppie or
intellectual or something she's now
joined them
because they're out trying to damn save
mankind against the zombie hordes you
know and they're crude and crass and
hanging the zombies up in trees and
shooting them and [ __ ] but none of that
matters in the apocalypse and both
movies
are basically an exploration of that you
know yeah you could be a tough
businessman from new york or whatever
and then the uh the black office boys
can still whip your ass and be right so
that's what that's what survival or it
was all about gsb that's the essence of
it
the natural order who you are as a
person
and honestly uh i have to say i kind of
like the way they uh the way cooper
ended in this one
i think yes i think that was a good idea
yeah they gave him a
a worse ending which
which he deserves
but he's actually more of a dick than he
was in the first one i mean he was a big
dick
he was a dick in the first one but he
was like an even more massive
one well then this one he was borderline
killer before in the first one he was an
angry grumpy coward really yeah who was
trying to protect his status right and
didn't want to be told what to do by any
other any other dude much less a black
dude yeah there's no way he's and who is
younger than him so
you know no just he's just an [ __ ]
but there are a lot of [ __ ] like
that lots of them
you know um but it's all true life
lessons you know that dude's like that's
the way it really is that's what dudes
are like that you know yeah and i mean
and even in this one where he's just
like a huge huge gaping anus dude but
it's still realistic because like i said
there are totally i mean you know we've
all encountered people like this
this this this version of cooper not
only is he uncooperative because he's a
coward and doesn't want to look bad
and
defend himself by lashing out
when you have a success around him he
actively tries to undermine you to make
you wrong yeah you know what i mean so
he didn't do that in the first one from
what i remember
i think well he did but i think it was
more subtle or subtle it was more subtle
yeah here it's a lot more obvious yeah
um he got what's coming to him though he
was the example of who not to be
definitely yeah don't be that guy yeah
don't be that good in case of a zombie
apocalypse yeah well yeah at one point
at one point where uh you know the other
kid
tom uh you know the younger guy with the
girlfriend who was judy rose that was
her name yeah um and he and some of the
zombies had like busted through the door
that they had nailed up and so you know
tom is over there like trying to hold
the [ __ ] and you know cooper's over
there just like looking at him yeah i
didn't want to he's like hey you gonna
like help me out or you'd be too scared
he was yeah he was too scared and then
finally he comes over he's like oh here
here's the thing that you can put nails
in and i'm going back over here
he was a coward he just he couldn't
admit it to himself that he was a coward
yeah so he just had to be so he had to
go in the total opposite direction and
be like really arrogant like why even
bother doing that that's not gonna work
and right all that other kind of [ __ ]
because he was scared shitless uh yeah
big time
uh mike says this the thing the fly and
the blob are some of the best remakes
yeah i would agree with all of those
yeah uh and i would really i've really
really been
hankering to like watch the remake of
the blog
because i remember loving it i remember
liking we ought to just buy it on dvd we
should i remember actually seeing that
in the theater and being like blown away
i mean like well the thing about what
the 50s
was good i mean the 50s one is a classic
but it's kind of more of like a goofy
almost like a comedy kind of i mean it's
yeah man when i was a kid they used to
play this [ __ ] on the on a saturday
monster matinees and when that scene
where that dude
falls into the mirror and he's fighting
it in the blinds and it's on him he
scared the [ __ ] out i mean i was kidding
well i mean if if you think about that
really happening i mean that would be
horrifying being like so the fact that
they took it like in the 80s
and they made it actually scary yeah um
and they actually did like there's like
i remember the special effects and it
being really good
um you know so because because like i
said as a concept that's a really scary
concept like an alien slime that could
come there and like consume you yeah
when when the old hillbilly was out
there and found the meteor and it went
down a stick and god i was like oh
no
it was small when it got on it
[ __ ] was totally believable
that one and the thing are believable
aliens yeah if you ask me and like i
said probably the scariest kinds of yeah
because they're more like just creatures
and you wouldn't be able to like an
alien amoeba that just [ __ ] absorbs
everything it gets bigger oh man yeah
see that would be like the worst yeah
that was that's that would only be a
notch below the thing yeah which could
like copy things the thing was the same
thing other thing it could copy things
and it had a mind and it could [ __ ]
steal brains and thought and
and make machines which makes it even
worse make it totally unbeatable
the blob was just an mb but it was just
an animal
yeah that just like did it was
mindlessly it was just like
which like i said that's pretty
horrifying it's got its own scariness to
it yeah that's what i'm saying
uh but yeah somebody said uh fourth row
down said the dawn of the dead remake uh
has just been put up on netflix any
thoughts is this the 2004 one because
honestly
i thought it was pretty damn good i saw
that in the theater as well 2004 i think
that was 2004. i don't
i got to remember which one that was you
probably were on the roofs and they were
talking between two buildings using the
signs guy was in the gun shop i think so
yeah
it's been a while since i've seen it i
saw it in the theater and i might have
seen it one more time right
uh no need for me too says such a solid
performance from mr todd we're talking
about yeah 1998. when his best move i
mean i love tony todd i'll watch him in
anything um but
i had actually forgotten how good he was
in this movie i mean between this and
candy man because candy man came out
like two years after this i think
in his candyman outfit you can't get an
idea of his physicality especially at
this point in time he's tall man he's
really tall i didn't realize he was that
tall either but there's like there was
one shot in particular in the night of
living dead remake where he's standing
next to barbara like patricia tallman
and i was like holy crap
it looks like a foot taller
way taller than her and he's real thin
and he's a good-looking guy and he's
just it's a shame we didn't get more of
todd
back
in his prime i don't want to say he's
over the hill i mean [ __ ] we saw some of
his local [ __ ] horror movies what was
the one what was that well he was in um
hatchet right yeah
that one hatchet movie he was great in
that um he we just need to get more of
todd before you know while he's still
with us in the polite way but yeah he's
not that old
we need more because i feel like he's
really really underrated he's underrated
everything i see him in he's like the
best thing yeah yeah yeah he's got a
good voice
that too well he's got like a real good
charisma like a really good screen
presence he has like a really good
screen presence he was kind of uh um
a lot a lot he should have done a lot of
the same stuff that james earl jones did
he's kind of like another james earl
jones it's just yeah
for some reason they didn't cast him
you know they probably because they
could get james jones probably
yeah james jones was older but you know
what i mean he still had that same
impressive voice i liked it and he was
he'd been really good in a conan movie
that's true yeah i think he could have
been a dulce dune
yeah david june says the 2004 dawn of
the dead was awesome yeah i remember it
being like really really good like i
said i saw in the theater
i was kind of like skeptical as i always
am when i go see a remake and i was like
where are you remaking dawn of the dead
really but then when i went inside i was
like ah all right i'll allow it
that was actually pretty [ __ ] good
um you know it's it's just that there's
so many bad ones bad remakes that you
know remakes kind of get a bad
rap you know what i mean i didn't even
hate
the texas chainsaw massacre remake it
wasn't great but it wasn't as bad as i
was expecting now the friday the 13th
remake
can suck a dick that was really not good
but
you know
uh
yeah
spaniard said i also saw this movie by
accident while scrolling through the tv
one late saturday night the movie really
engaged you yeah like the original one
or the 1991 i don't know
um
tony todd was good in the rock too oh
[ __ ] i forgot he was in that i forgot
which one was the rock was that the one
about alcatraz not alcatraz what am i
talking about i haven't seen it yeah
okay i did but it was like a long time
ago
um
[Music]
no need for me to said yeah that era was
notorious for casting way too old actors
as teens yeah we're talking about steve
mcqueen
yeah he's in high school i'm like
yeah how many times did he get health
back
right he's like
he looked even older than that because
we were talking about that yesterday how
um
and i you know it's kind of like a joke
now because so many of these 50s teen
movies i mean obviously like those
actors were [ __ ]
in their late 20s at the very least and
because people tended to look older than
their age back then just for whatever
reason i don't know if it was the
hairstyles or
the clothing or they had
their lifestyle like they didn't look as
young or the plastic surgery wasn't as
good or i don't really know what it was
but
every single time you see like teenagers
in that they're just very clearly they
look at like they're at least 35 years
old business says they're remaking blade
runner again no they're not
they can't be remaking blade runner
because they already made a sequel to it
and then that that they were going to
make a third one
yeah i thought that's what he's talking
about baby and somebody said uh somebody
said they were making another
ghostbusters honestly i saw the pre the
preview for that and that's okay it
looks pretty that looks pretty fun
actually they're bringing back most of
the original cast but it's gonna be i
think it's gonna focus around egon's
granddaughter yeah but it looks like
they got annie potts and it looks like
they got
zuul and all the [ __ ] originals
the dude from stranger things the kid
from stranger things well he's not
really a kid yeah but you know because
he's like an older teenager now but he's
a dozer and [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
demon dog
things
remember when [ __ ] rick miranda's
turned into the demon dog yeah yeah
[Laughter]
man the original ghostbusters is easily
one of my favorite movies in the 80s i
could watch that movie over and over and
over again yeah
i got the second one too it's not it's
not not that the second one's still
worth watching yeah but it's i mean it's
really not it's hard to beat that for
you it's really hard yeah the first one
was just so good yeah that i mean it's
still funny like the comedy is still
funny
um you know it's it's just really really
tough act to follow yeah
uh but yeah so do we have anything else
we need to say about no i could just
recommend i recommend both of them yes
and uh somebody said that um that
somebody had put a version up on youtube
for free of this okay and like i said um
you know we found if you have an fye and
a mall or something like that uh it
looks like they're selling off the dvd
for five bucks because that's where i
got it um and it's definitely worth
watching especially like like a lot of
george romero films because like i said
george mary actually did write the
screenplay for this it was based on his
original screenplay with uh john russo
and tom savini directed it so
you know can't really go wrong like it's
not super gory it's not like expect to
be like a big gore fest and it's pretty
similar to the original but they
they tweaked a couple of things and it's
totally good like i said tony todd
completely makes it worth watching but
everybody else is good in it too and i
really really like the the dude that
plays cooper is just such a giant
[ __ ]
he's just such a giant dick it's just
[ __ ]
he's really fun to watch but not like
over the top he's not like a mustache
twirling villain or anything but
he's just
you and and the ending of what happens
to him at the end is just really really
satisfying i think we were watching it
and i was just kind of like yeah
because i had forgotten that happened
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
talking about i don't know what we'd be
talking about we'll either be talking
about squid game because we finished
watching it last night finally um or we
might watch something else and talk
about that we don't know we don't know
uh so we'll be back tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by
bye